y es que lastimosamente los países de
américa latina como región no tienen un
foro lo suficientemente adecuado para
interactuar con los eeuu el diálogo al
interior de la oea es distinto que si
hubiese una una unidad latinoamericana
para trabajar con eeuu entonces lo que
yo quiero mencionar con ello es que la
relación de eeuu es principalmente
bilateral y yo creo que se va a seguir
desarrollando de esa forma a menos de
que el presidente yo wyden quisiera
impulsar una agenda multilateral ya sea
al interior de la oea o de otros bloques
subregionales principalmente entonces
estas serían yo creo mis observaciones
acerca de cuáles son las implicaciones
de la relación de joe biden hacia
américa latina haciendo una salvedad
también y es que estratégicamente
américa latina no ha no ha sido una
prioridad en los últimos cuatro años
sino que también hay otras
la relación bilateral con china como la
situación en oriente medio como la
relación con los países europeos tanto
individual como colectivamente al
interior de la unión europea que generan
dentro del pensamiento político
estadounidense más interés que
particularmente esa relación frente a
américa latina hay un electorado que al
cual le interesa mucho la región por
supuesto que sí especialmente en la
florida hay un sector importante en
washington dice que ve a américa latina
como una región importante y ahí la
presión tal vez de potencias extra
externas que han venido ganando peso en
los últimos años como china como rusia
eventualmente unas relaciones dinámicas
con algunos países entre irán y algunos
países de la región pero digamos que
estratégicamente dentro del círculo de
poder de
el sistema federal estadounidense dentro
del gobierno estadounidense hay otros
problemas estratégicos en política
exterior que requieren de una acción más
pronta y asimismo también por último
quisiera mencionar en la elección de
mauricio claver carone fue sin duda
alguna un elemento importante que
realizó esta administración y de la cual
el presidente yo bailé no estuvo de
acuerdo dijo que al interior del
congreso habría un menor apoyo a esta
particular administración entesa y vamos
a ver si realmente se confirma que va a
haber un distanciamiento de eeuu del
vídeo cual quería peligroso para la
región porque eeuu es el que más aporta
para los proyectos de desarrollo que se
llevan a cabo en distintos países de la
región y ahí hay que también tener en
cuenta qué es lo que va a suceder con
ese foro con la oea y con otros con
otras relaciones bilaterales que
revisten particular interés méxico
brasil chile colombia la situación en
venezuela